bonjour marc fesneau bonjour ministre de
l'agriculture et de la sécurité
alimentaire ministre aussi un peu des
forêts car l'office national des forêts
dépend de votre ministère on va parler
de là près de ce qui sera fait après
cette catastrophe mais pour l'instant il
ya toujours le feu on l'entendait encore
dans le journal en gironde même s'il
commence à être un peu plus limitée il
ya urgence et il ya un gouvernement qui
est obligé s'expliquer sur le manque de
moyens dont certains l'accusent oui
alors c'est toujours les sujets qui
viennent quand il ya des incendies de
cette ampleur on essaie d'en face à des
phénomènes qui sont exceptionnels c'est
plus de 20 mille hectares en gironde
1500 dans le finistère
1501 des bouches du rhône avec plus de
300 départs de feu je crois qu'ils sont
qui sont à l'oeuvre d'abord salué
l'engagement des sapeurs-pompiers
salants lieu également des forces de
sécurité civile les gendarmes les
policiers puis salue aussi les
forestiers ceux de l'office national des
forêts puis les forestiers privés qui
sont très engagées pour essayer de
lutter et puis aussi les agriculteurs
qui apportent leurs mains fortes aussi
social relationnel pardon plus parfois
10 il manque de moyens mais canada il ya
un sujet sur les moyens alors d'abord
dire qu'est ce que c'est quel est l'état
des choses on est le pays d'europe qui a
la plus grande flotte aérienne qui
permet de lutter contre les incendies
sans doute ce type d'événement doit nous
faire réfléchir le président de la
république se rendra cet après midi en
gironde à complémenter les moyens aller
plus loin la sécurité civile s'est vu
doté d'un budget en augmentation de 44%
dans les cinq dernières années ça veut
dire qu on a déjà été au rendez vous
sans doute qu'il faudra aller plus loin
pour faire face à des incendies dont on
voit bien que les épisodes de sécheresse
et la canicule vient de les rendre
beaucoup plus prégnant c'est très rare
qu'on ait des incendies dans le
finistère je pense aux incendies qui a
lieu dans les banques qui ont lieu dans
les monts d'arrée mon arrivée à
concentrer les moyens sur les zones les
plus à risque le bassin méditerranéen un
peu la lironde quand même vous dites en
creux c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'était
pas armé s'ils affrontaient sénégal
bacon qui met qui éclatent un peu
partout finale moi je je je constate
qu'on a des moyens qu'on a dû déployer
des moyens importants sans doute
faudra-t-il aller aller plus loin mais
il déjà en a mais suffisante toujours
pardon de le dire comme ça c'est
toujours commode de dire une fois qu'on
a des événements de dire si on avait su
si on avait pu si on avait voulu la
vérité c'est que le gouvernement a déjà
été à l'oeuvre puisque les budgets un
message à la loire oui ouverte à voir
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans la sécurité
pour la sécurité civile puisque en
augmenter le budget qui à 850 millions
qui sont prévues
pour remettre à niveau la flotte et donc
on avait ça ne date pas c'est pas une
mesure qui date d'aujourd'hui c'est une
mesure qui avait été prise avant donc on
avait pleinement pris conscience il faut
que ça monte en puissance effectivement
au delà de la lutte contre le feu est-ce
qu'il faudra repenser les forêts
lorsqu'elles seront replantés après
cette catastrophe on a deux sujets sans
doute là dedans est ce qu'il faut par
exemple planté que des résineux
d'origine et un premier sujet c'est
pendant une forêt qui a une tendance
structurelle à dépérir compte tenu des
événements climatiques et du dérèglement
climatique
je pense à ce qui se passe dans l'est
avec un dépérissement liés à une maladie
et 2 d essence qui sont peut-être moins
adapté ou pas assez adapté y compris
dans des forêts de feuillus compris dans
des régions comme les miennes et donc on
a besoin de réorienter les plantations
entre val de loire centre-var isoloirs
vous avez raison de le préciser et donc
on a besoin de réorienter les
plantations c'est un travail de temps
long là aussi il ya des moyens et là
aussi on n'a pas attendu cet épisode là
pour le faire puisque le président de la
république a annoncé y compris dans la
campagne présidentielle qui souhaitait
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin il ya
plus d'un milliard d'euros qui sont
prévues pour faire la replantation les
pins par exemple quand ils partent comme
info globalement réfléchir sur la
question du dépérissement et modifier le
les plantations qu'on a dans nos forêts
et puis deux des moyens lui qui fasse
qu'on n'ait plus de diversité sans doute
qu'on ait plus de ce qu'on appelle des
pare feu c'est-à-dire des banques qui
sont sans plantations mais qui
permettent de ralentir en cas d'
incendies et les affaires de desserte
forestière donc on a toute une panoplie
d'outils je rallierai la semaine
prochaine un certain nombre d'acteurs
pour retravailler sur ces questions il
n'est pas temps pour l'instant vous le
comprendrez puisque là il est temps de
lutter contre l'incendié je répète il
faut saluer l'engagement des pompiers
qui ont préservé beaucoup de bien et
beaucoup de personnes et après il sera
le temps de la reconstruction de la
replantation vous nous annoncer qu'il y
aura une réunion la semaine prochaine à
votre ministère sur ces questions ce
avec des collègues de la transition
écologique c'est souvent des
propriétaires privés oui qui possèdent
ces forêts ce que pour les contraindre à
planter là on peut les orienter il ya
déjà des dispositifs dans le code rural
qui permettent d'orienter un certain
nombre de choses y compris en terme de
renouvellement y compris en termes de
lutte contre les incendies et donc c'est
avec eux qu'on va travailler et avec
évidemment les gestionnaires publics que
sont le nf en particulier les communes
forestières aussi marc fesneau a qu à
côté de ces incendies exceptionnel il ya
une autre conséquence catastrophique de
cette situation météo c'est la
sécheresse qui se prolongent qui dure
depuis des semaines depuis des mois plus
de 70 départements français je crois
115 8 75 exactement ont aujourd'hui des
mesures de restrictions d'eau est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin est-ce qu'il
faut que ces mesures soient davantage
appliquées qu'elles ne le sont là encore
en termes de mesures d'urgence a aussi
essayé de préciser chose on a un
dispositif qui est très rodée qui est un
dispositif graduée qui va de des
premières mesures jusqu'à des mesures
d'interdiction strict sur un certain
nombre de l'utilisation de l'eau moi
j'en appelle à la responsabilité de
chacun au fonds dans des périodes comme
celle là est ce qu'ils aient besoin de
remplir sa piscine et ce qu'ils aient
besoin
de sa voiture il a besoin rien ne
l'interdît aussi s'il ya un certain
nombre d'arrêtés préfectoraux qui
l'interdisent après il faut que ce soit
appliquée mais on va pas aller dans
chaque maison vérifier ce que font les
gens c'est une possibilité mais la
question n'est pas celle
beaucoup d'eau qui est gâchée en ce
moment alors qu'il ya des contrôles sur
l'agriculture en ont besoin il ya des
contrôles sur le terrain les
agriculteurs ont besoin certains
industriels ont besoin donc les
agriculteurs font leur part parce qu'ils
sont très contrôlés ils font leur part
de réduction de l'utilisation d'eau avec
des conséquences sur les récoltes et
puis chacun doit penser que n'importe
quel geste qui permet d'économiser l'eau
dans ces périodes là est un geste
important chaque jour qui passe 10 et
christiane lambert la présidente de la
fnsea il ya quelques jours on voit les
cultures dépérir il ya des cultures
particulières qui souffre par exemple le
maïs qui a besoin de beaucoup d'eau
est-ce que vous avez déjà prévu des
mesures de dédommagement des doses
agriculteurs au cas par cas on n'est pas
là aussi on est au milieu de la crise
dont il n'appartiendra de regarder d'ici
quelques semaines les conséquences
réelles il ya de sûr certaines cultures
et puis ya des conséquences aussi sur
l'alimentation animale puisqu'il ya un
certain nombre de prairies qui ne sont
plus utilisables qui n'auront pas de
repousse et qui fera qu' il me manquait
de l'alimentation pour le bétail et donc
ça on a besoin de faire un état des
lieux à la fin de l'été c'est plutôt
quand les animaux seront rentrés et sont
allés table comme on dit cet hiver qu'il
faudra qu'on ait anticipé cette question
là pour pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'alimentation soit au rendez vous pour
les animaux donc on a des tas début va
se traduire par des aides alors ya des
dispositifs ça me permet de dire deux
choses les dispositifs classiques qu'on
appelle le dispositif de calamité
agricole le gouvernement a toujours été
au rendez vous sur d'autres épisodes
climatiques je pense à ce qui s'est
passé sur la grêle ou le gel
ici donc on avait le déclencher le 10
mai c'est le gâteau était déclenché puis
à des mesures d'exonérations de charges
et des mesures d'exonération de deux
reports de charges des mesures
d'exonérations sur le foncier non bâti
donc on va activer l'ensemble des
dispositifs l'important c'est d'avoir un
état des lieux puis 1-2 sujet ces
systèmes d'assurance récolte qu'on va
mettre en oeuvre c'est l'objet d'une loi
qui avait été porté par mon prédécesseur
je n'ai demandé deux jours encore
écouter la loi a été votée a été
promulguée le 5 d'avancé sur guingamp
nat assurance récolte on sait pour
l'instant il ya un agriculteur il ya
bien un système d'assurance récolte on
voit bien que la multiplication des
aléas le rendait le système obsolète
donc on à réformer ce système est
l'objectif c'est qu'au 1er janvier 2023
il soit bien alors c'est à dire dans un
camp dans un temps très court j'avais
encore une réunion hier soir y compris
avec christiane lambert et d'autres
organisations agricoles pour travailler
sur cette question mais l'assurance
récolte qu'on comprenne bien ça va
concerner tous les agriculteurs il
faudra souscrire à des compagnies
privées c'est d'étape qui sera derrière
c'est à la fois l'état aidera la
souscription de contrats d'assurance
récolte puis après le système
assurantiel et puis à la part des
cotisations des agriculteurs donc c'est
un système qui vise à mieux sécuriser
c'est un élément de sécurisation puis un
troisième élément pardon sur des
éléments sécheresse il faut qu'on arrive
on arrive à déployer dans le territoire
des suites de ce qu'on a appelé var
haendel qui était à un moment de grande
discussion et de débat sur la gestion de
l'eau on a des éclats d'os on a des
périodes sans eau du tout qu'il n'y
paraît avec beaucoup d'eau et donc il
faut qu'on puisse en récupérer une
partie pour les périodes de disette
comme celle que nous connaissions parce
que sans eau n'ya pas d'agriculture il
faudra qu'on apprenne à vivre avec ça il
ya donc à modifier les pratiques et à
régler la question de look marc fesneau
on a parlé des incendies de la
sécheresse est un autre sujet chaud
cette fois au sens figuré qui est en ce
moment en débat à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la loi assure pouvoir d'achat vous
étiez ministre des relations avec le
parlement dans le précédent gouvernement
c'est en expert un peu que vous voyez ce
qui se passe ça avance très doucement il
ya vingt articles dans cette loi est
trois seulement ont été votés
normalement tout doit être bouclé avant
ce week-end pourquoi ça coince est-ce
que les compromis qu'avait promis le
gouvernement va finalement c'est juste
des mots c'est ce que vous reproche la
gauche vraiment mais pour avoir un
compromis faut que chacun bouche de
position et moi je vois un certain
nombre d'attitudes pas partout pas sur
tous les bancs de gens qui ne veulent
pas bouger de position donc de compromis
c'est pas je tiens ma position et venez
à ma position sinon y'a pas de compromis
c'est ça le principe d'un compromis lors
et flare que chacun apprenne le
gouvernement est prêt il ya un certain
nombre de travaux qui ont été faits avec
y compris les gens de l'opposition y
compris avec les parlementaires de la
majorité le temps est un peu long on est
dans une période où il faut que chacun
apprenne à travailler avec la volonté du
compromis dit pas sur tous les bancs
justement le rassemblement national lui
a voté
notamment le premier un cycle de suranné
tebbal principalement que je pense et
oui mais est-ce que ça vous connaît
l'aubaine de conscience politique juste
pardon que le racing en national associé
s'impose à vous permettre de menacer le
débat démocratique chacun personne n'est
obligé de voter ce qu'il a à voter il
n'y a pas demandé impératif deuxième
élément personne ne s'offusque que la
semaine dernière le rassemblement
national avec la france insoumise et
fait sauter l'article 2 du projet de loi
sanitaire donc cesser le débat
démocratique un état d'âme latine en
fait c'est pas une question mais ça vous
êtes l'important ce n'est pas ça
l'important c'est d'avoir une majorité
me semble que celle une partie des
socialistes c'est une partie des élèves
il ya des gens avec lequel on peut
trouver un terrain d'entente pour
arriver à une majorité donc la question
n'est pas de se polariser sur le
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national fait bien ce qu'il veut il est
libre de voter ou de ne pas voter il le
fait souvent d'ailleurs avec
l'association enjeu tant mieux non c'est
pas une question de marange est la
question n'est pas marrant j'ai la
question c'est d'avoir un équilibre
politique qui tienne la route sur la
durée et donc il me semble que dans le
champ républicain avec les républicains
avec une partie des socialistes il ya
les voies et moyens de trouver des
compromis dernières questions réponses
courtes s'il vous plaît vladimir poutine
tout autre sujet mais on reparle
d'agriculture et de céréales dit qu'il
veut bien aider le déblocage des
céréales ukrainienne qui sont bloqués
dans les ports aujourd'hui à cause de la
guerre à condition qu'on lève l'embargo
sur sa propre production qu'est ce que
vous en pensez il ya un mot pour résumer
cette pensée ou cette proposition c'est
ça s'appelle du chantage si on a un
problème aujourd'hui de céréales je
voyais mon collègue allemand hier à
berlin si on a un problème aujourd'hui
de céréales c'est parce que on ne peut
plus sortir les céréales en particulier
du port d'odessa donc c'est la volonté
de la dîmière poutine faut pas inverser
les rôles et responsabilités la
responsabilité de vladimir poutine c'est
de laisser circuler les céréales parce
que ça a des conséquences sur le prix
des céréales et sa déco ou technicienne
aussi les ca des conséquences sur sur
les pays limitrophes y compris les pays
méditerranéens donc il ya une
responsabilité n'inversons pas les rôles
et ne faisons pas par pitié des céréales
et de l'alimentation un objet de
chantage parce que là on rentre dans une
logique qui se réunit gilles logique que
je crois délétère merci bon 6e marc
fesneau au ministre de l'agriculture